if you're going to go and ask for advice
about intimacy with someone who never
really seems to be intimate with anyone
they're going to first off not have a
particularly fantastic perspective I
don't think unless they're unbelievably
incisive but secondly there's going to
be a little bit of a perverse incentive
that they don't want their friend to
start to pull away from them oh so
interesting I'm going to give you the
advice that makes what I'm doing seem
like a good idea and also keeps you as a
compatriot so that we can both continue
to do this together you know where The
Sisterhood girl you don't need him etc
etc it's like maybe yeah maybe that's
maybe that's true but like if you are
unable guy or girl is unable to get
yourself a partner or unable to find
friends like no dude you don't need that
friend anymore it's like the subtext of
that is you can hang out with me I'm
your people